das ist auch so dass ist wirklich so
häufig bei allen jungs sonst bin ich ein
bisschen am arsch ist willkommen bayer
neuen video und da mein letzter teil
oder mein erster teil von jungs alleine
vs jungs mit mädchen so megabad com ist
hab ich gerade kommen aus direkten in
zwei teilen daher und den gibt es heute
und ja ich muss euch sagen dass der teil
leider wieder ohne eine weibliche person
abgedreht wird da irgendwie scheiße blöd
und plötzlich und deswegen also wenn du
dich bewerben willst schreibe mir
einfach mit einem bild ein www spaß beim
druck auf jeden fall ist dann auch voll
egal ich will gar nicht lange land wenn
es euch gefällt dann lass doch nach oben
da und wir fangen natürlich angelpunkt 1
also passt auf leute punkt eins ich will
gar nicht zu viel verraten es geht
einfach darum make up auftragen das hört
sich jetzt erst mal scheiße an aber
schaut mal rein
einfach los make up muss seinen traum
make up das ist so unnötig obwohl es
gibt sogar jungs die make up trage voll
die komischen oder thema vor ich würde
jetzt make up tragen kannst du mich noch
ernst nehmen
punkt zwei ganz locker weg einfach musik
hören ja das ist auch so dass ist
wirklich so furchtbar jungs sonst bin
ich ein bisschen schiss
wie gerne wäre ich nur justin bieber ist
das bitte für mich kannst du was cool
ist anderen vielleicht rap oder sogar
sprechen soll ich jetzt hier gleich
anfangen zu weinen was die sonne scheint
mal ganz ehrlich kommst also wenn du
sowas hört er fast so schön wie das
zwiebel nach aus jetzt ja jetzt auch
schon mal punkten
drei angekommen und zwar ist das ganz
einfach essen machen wie ich es mache
wenn ich alleine bin ich kreiert mir da
immer sowas weil ich denke mal so
bestimmt vor lecker und dann esse ich
das sogar
schaut mal rein irgendwie habe ich voll
ungarisch wäre schon was
und 13 jetzt fragt sich nur was ich da
drauf machen
mayuka job marmelade cornflakes für
kommen wir versuchen so jetzt haben wir
mario ketchup senf marmelade käse bier
fehlt noch fast vergessen
sollte ganz schnell was zu essen machen
so versuchen zumindest so okay ich habe
für mich eins mit salami und für dich
mit salami sorry ich kann wirklich nur
so hat aber deswegen muss ja auch
eigentlich dürfen mitkochen
ja und jetzt sind punkt nummer vier und
zwei punkt nummer vier instagram so
fotos durch gucken
das ist auch lustig obwohl ich weiß gar
nicht ob das überall so ist aber bei mir
ist das so alter dies geil war direkt
man like unten verloren ballack und ich
lag einfach noch zehn fotos vielleicht
zieht ihr das ja dann und folgt mir auch
nike nike nike ja jetzt mal abwarten ob
ich die hübsch finde er zeigt x factor
jetzt bloß nichts falsches
aber lange nicht so wie du ja leute so
viel dazu erstmalig würde sagen falls
ihr noch bock auf den dritten teil hab
dann lasst auf jeden fall noch nach oben
da würd mich sehr freuen als ein abo nie
vergessen auch nichts zu verpassen ins
würde man grobe alles schön eingebildet
hier oben auf der rechten seite des auf
jeden fall ab dass mein letztes video
war seine wörter erraten challenge auf
jeden fall ganz cool geworden
und wer mega geil wenn jetzt hoffentlich
sagen wir sehen uns wieder auf mittwoch
kommt neues format von mir und checkt es
dann auf jeden fall ab und 15 uhr